قالت وكاله ريانوفسكي الروسيه ان قوات
فادنير سيطرت على مواقع جديده مهمه داخل
المنطقه الصناعيه وسط مدينه بخموت كما
قالت
ونقلت نقله نعم مصر موالي لروسيا في اقليم
دومبا سنه
سيطرات على مواقع داخل مصنع معالجه الصلب
على الضفه الغربيه من نهر بخموتكا ووفق
المصر فان ذلك سيسهل السيطره على المنطقه
الصناعيه ويجعل منها منطلقا لهجمات فاغنر
على ما تبقى من احياء يسيطر عليها الجيش
الاوكراني من جهه قال موقع ريبار العسكري
ان سلاح الجوي الروسي شن ضربات مكثفه على
مواقع الجيش الاوكراني وسط مدينه باكموت
وفي بلده مجاوره
اعلنت سلطات خيرسون المواليه لروسيا مقتله
مدنيا في قصف مدفعيا اوكراني استهدف مدينه
نوفا كخوفكا على الضفه اليسرى من نهر
دينيبرو جنوبيه اوكرانيا وقالت ان القوات
الاوكرانيه
الواقعه على الضفه اليسرى من النهر بشكل
متواصل باستخدام اسلحه غربيه السنه واكدت
ان القصف المدفعي الاخير استهدف مناطق
سكنيه وسط نوفوريا كخوفكا وحيث كل المركزي
في المدينه